So, like we said earlier in this lesson, we've actually been talking about kinds
of meta-cognition throughout this course, even if we didn't call it that at
the time. We were talking about agents reflecting on their own knowledge, and
correcting it when they were introduced to a mistake. Earlier in this lesson,
we also talked about the possibility that an agent would reflect on the learning
process that led it to the incorrect knowledge, and
correct that learning process, as well. Back during partial order planning,
we talked about agents that could balance multiple plans and
resolve conflicts between those plans. This could be seen as a form of
meta-cognition as well. The agent plans out a plan for achieving one goal,
a plan for achieving the other goal, and then thinks about its own plans for
those two goals. Then it detects the conflict between those two plans and
it resolves that conflict accordingly. Then it detects the conflict between
those two plans and creates a new plan to avoid that conflict.
Here the agent is reasoning over its own planning process. We saw this in
production systems as well. We had an agent that reached an impasse, it had two
different pitches which is suggested and it couldn't decide between the two.
Let's find a new learning goal to find a rule to choose between those pitches.
It then selected a learning strategy, chunking, went into its memory, found
a case, and chunked a rule that would it resolve that impasse. In this case,
the agent used that impasse to set up a new learning goal. It didn't select
the strategy, strategy selection, to achieve that learning goal. We can also see
medicognition in version spaces. Our agent has the notion of specific and
general models, and it also has the notion of convergence. The agent is
consistently thinking about it's own specific and general model, and looking for
opportunities to converge them down into one model of the concept. And finally,
we can very clearly see metacognition in our lesson on diagnosis.
We talked about how all the results for our treatment become new data for our
iterative process of diagnosis. If our treatment didn't spond desirable results,
it also sponds data for the metal layer. Not only do we still want to diagnose
the current malfunction,. But we also want to diagnose, why we weren't able to
diagnose it correctly in the first place. So, now we're diagnosing the problem
with our diagnosing process. So as we can see, meta cognition's actually been
implicit in several of the topics we've talked about in this course.